welcome to this video playing looked on
looked on would be the German type of
pronunciation it's been on on icc for a
while but it seems another Platon or her
never know so we have anti goon fault i
can actually transpose back to the goon
partner but probably try something else
for a change this is one interesting
line Quincy thread yeah this is not so
good because of the Queen Queen move
here I had this recently in a in a game
here and now White has a very nice play
in the center with black some King site
compromised check
yeah it's very tempting to play h4 h5 em
and I'm willing to fall for this this
fall for this temptation this is
probably a wrong expression ok anyway
let's see h5 night h2h five it all looks
good I think I had a very similar game
recently then I try them in wet the
bishop going it does not have any good
square back to see eight probably yeah I
think c8 was the better square really
unseeded at least allows the Queen to
attack something but okay so aged six
now on is this takes an IG form or just
night here and then threatening age six
yeah it looks very good for wine anyway
but what exactly is the best
continuation Knight f3 on the night over
here I'm not sure h6 is really
substantial or should I play age six and
to open up come on I just push this to
open up the H file the sir should be
very dangerous in any case then long
castles and just play on the H file yeah
I needed to speed up a bit i was
spending so much time in the in the
start of the started the game so now my
idea is Knight f3 and possibly just wow
Wow ah there no back this is not going
to work I don't I don't believe that
because it will open up even the the
long diagonal potentially and and the
bishop on c4 is is opened no no no I
don't don't believe that okay it takes
there is Bishop be six winning the Queen
er it's 11 possibility on or others I
mean taking here it's not working yet on
h7 very close though okay Bishop e6 is
the easiest move to play he will
sacrifice the Queen Bishop TX group
takes rook takes but that's not a mating
attack I'd like to play for a meeting
attack here early with look aged one
coming threading also Bishop takes d5
down to one minute something that's
always always interesting that I managed
to completely screw up the time
situation now it looks it looks like h6
so i just take g5 i think and then take
h6 that's by far the easiest yeah okay
let's chat going to take and now one
idea is queen bee three but this quincy
six
Bishop c5 is also not bad but probably
it's not winning k i'll try to keep it
keep it simple for the moment just one
minute 15 so that probably was some some
stronger continuation that one that won
the game immediately but I couldn't
calculate it I just want to play let's
say f3 then take on g5 it will be a very
good position for white in any case so I
probably didn't play the most forceful
line but not bad really okay if I go
here Queen g7 yeah maybe I shouldn't pin
the rook threatening rook h6 Queen g7
rook age 7 and wins I believe it behind
warning
and now it's not a winning so maybe
activate even more here Queen h3
possibly yeah why does not wear black is
not exactly spoiled for choice IAM and
now there is let's check down
look do you want check irritated me
check this is not working I don't tell
me I'm not winning here this is check
unbelievable really chanting winning a
pic no I'm not winning a piece
unbelievable check check I cannot
believe that this game is still running
really this is this is one of the worst
I can think of what I did I mean from
this position not not finding a mate is
really amazing or I click Add win
check it's unfortunately still still
winning check check check check check
check mate I still have what deck I mean
I really think if I if I ask the
computer here it will show me a false
made and totally sure about it rooke age
7 is the force made yeah okay I'm just
I'm just something I can't just take g7
of course what the mmm yeah oh I really
should I should get some I should get
dinner or something instead of check
playing chess everyone ok everything
winds but I mean how easy can do you
want it to be check and then resins
check I'm really so we continue and it's
of call it's always + 3 + 4 but we need
six plus eight and simply Queen f5s
chassis level check okay Jade I played
this like a total idiot Luke AJ look at
this I mean check ah ok chess or this
one check check check
the amazing thing is that this is still
bad for black but it is still totally
black bad for luck check yeah I sort of
played it like a person who is not able
to play a false mate or something just
always trading down to winning end game
which it was but ok I'm going to cook
some dinner now only way to solve this
thanks for watching